hello everyone thank you for having me
later sauce my name's Alan sake on I'm a
science communicator I posted through
science comedy shows future festivals
fireside chats I'm really passionate
about bridging the gap between science
and the public and getting people more
inspired to care more about the future
that we're building so so I so I have
this talk that I like giving around
three subjects and it's where did we
come from who are we and where are we
going and I'm just going to jump right
into it because there's a lot of content
and it's going to be a lot of different
things and I'm ready to surprise you so
let's go right into part one where did
we come from so this is a very succinct
way to explain that this is the Big Bang
and this is where we are now so we have
about Milky Way form this is about 13.7
billion years have went by sense
existence and Sun and Earth only form
about four and a half billion years ago
and we are here right now but are we
alone and so this is kind of a formation
of stars and galaxies the formations of
planets and stars and then this is where
we are now this is probably one of my
favorite pictures to like get a better
understanding of the cosmos with and
it's because it's a what's known as a
multiple star system so there we have a
single star system and it's really cool
like single stars are great but there
are actually things called binary stars
which are two star systems and multiple
star systems which are three four five
star systems and most of them are three
star systems but these are
really cool to just visualize and think
about because it's like what would it be
like living on a planet that had two
stars or three stars and this is a
pretty cool sophistic one-third of all
stars in our Milky Way galaxy are either
binary or multiple star systems so only
two-thirds are just single stars this is
one of another one of my favorite ways
to like visualize the cosmos so we have
you guys all know the habitable zone the
habitable zone is the area that's not
too hot not too cold it's just perfect
like the Goldilocks zone right in the
middle that enables a planet to foster
life from its host star and so this is
what is known as a tidally locked planet
so this planet is so close to its host
star that it's locked and that way you
have one side that's just ridiculously
hot and the other side is ridiculously
cold and this is what's crazy half yeah
doesn't work that a habitable zone has
formed on this crazy line right right in
between the super hot and super cold and
so life could have possibly evolved on
just one small strippable planet like
that so I just find this view really
good really way to expand my mind the
seamy law constant try and get through
this fast but this is a way that we
believe that bacteria tooks took in
sunlight for energy and turned water and
carbon dioxide into glucose to power
itself and as a byproduct released
oxygen and that fueled more this is
around the time of the Cambrian
explosion I really like to to illustrate
a this is a trilobite it's it's one of
those you know like like ocean floor
likes we'd be creatures like this and
a little Explorer and then the jumps
onto the its prey it's you know it's
very flat on this bottom this this one
is very interesting too
I don't know if it actually leaves that
hole or not so I'm like thinking like
could this guy potentially just everyday
just pop this I think that's it just
that's it for a movement just nothing
down okay it's safe I'm gonna go try to
find some food so this thinking like
humans take bar and like flying
airplanes and stuff and we have like
these creatures or that's their nervous
system it's just the eyeballs and food
and sleep and stuff like that so this is
Cambrian explosion about 500 million
years ago and then the reason why we
actually got on land a lot of it was due
to the evolution of the egg because now
we had animals from the ocean coming
onto land lay eggs eggs have all of the
nutrients necessary for a baby to to
break to slowly feed itself and get
enough energy from the nutrient side of
the egg to then burst out of an egg and
become an actual land animal
and so then weeks we experienced this
massive explosion of life as we know
about 65 million years ago we had all
these incredible dinosaurs I also like
to act these owl wings be so cool to be
a pterodactyl a massive like massive
pterodactyl flying in disguise and
Triceratops is really cool to like
fighting a Velociraptor or whatever the
storms and stuff just like really
immersing my mind into what it would be
like to live
the nervous system of these animals in
their mind would be definitely
accelerates my wisdom for understanding
where we came from
so let you guys know we experienced the
massive extinction of those dinosaurs
about 65 million years ago and this was
actually this asteroid was about the
size of us actually larger than Mount
Everest is what we believe the size of
it was and some of the further sorts of
like understandings of why why we're
here is because the dinosaurs got wiped
out humans would have never evolved if
it wasn't for the dinosaurs being wiped
out they would still be the ones that
control the earth so this is this is
Lucy Lucy is an evolution of the monkey
that was about to I think two million
years ago or so and then this is a
Neanderthal the Neanderthal is about a
hundred and fifty thousand two hundred
thousand years ago as well and most we
got away with out about 15,000 years ago
ago but you can kind of see the
evolutionary trajectory here and so look
it's our brother so ok Park - who are we
oh gee all right so who are we so what
do we do once we evolved for a monkey's
well one of the first things that we did
is we use stones as tools and so we were
able to do things like turn them into
weapons or help us slowly like chip away
at wood and make homes with it use them
as pottery for things like bowls and
things carry water and stuff like that
and then discovering fire you know a lot
a lot of people think like
we invent fighter well we don't quite
know it could have been just you know
lightning struck and we were like oh my
gosh and so then being able to control
it over time and cook food over it use
it for shelter use it for warmth use it
for building more civilization so this
is another one of a really interesting
photo that I like to act out because
this is an important way to understand
language and actually evolutionary
scientists say that language is one of
the most under stood developments of
human evolution because there's no way
for us to really understand how it came
to be but one of the ways that I'd like
to sort of get excited about languages
to think about how did these people
communicate back then okay so alright so
this so this person is trying to
assemble this what looks like maybe a
part of like a little teepee or maybe
part of the fire we don't know maybe
part of the house but so maybe this guy
knows how to assemble it better so he
walks over and goes like oh and just
shows through like grunts and stuff like
that how to do it and it shows that
stronger and then maybe over time they
start using things like and so they're
trying to say stick maybe are the
beginnings of the word stick maybe that
is the way that language involved is the
slow collaboration of using language as
a tool for us to get to know how to
label things and accelerate civilization
so we leveraged art to be able to tell
better stories so this is from a cave I
think 20,000 years ago I believe in
grants and our yak in France but but
this is a horse I believe and
or the person fool maybe but it's
beautiful art I think it's really crazy
to just think that like 20,000 years ago
humans somehow figured out how to make
these beautiful illustrations on walls
and tell stories through that this is
definitely one of my favorite pictures
about the who are we this is kind of
like the epitome of like the start of
civilization we talked about fire we
talked about the social cues we have you
know these stone tools that are now
being used to carrying water we have
stone tools here being used to hunt we
have now domesticated animals and the
probably most important of all is we've
now planted food next to our homes and
because we have now leveraged wheat and
been able to grow next to our homes now
we have the advancement of civilization
that can kind of like stay near these
homes and like we don't have to go out
and hunt as much and and that this makes
it easier for us to eat and grow our
population this is one of the next
largest advents in in human history is
to wheel this was actually completely
made of wood and this is like 5,000
years ago it's completely made of wood
which is crazy to think of because how
the hell did you even come up with a
piece of wood that big how do we figure
that out and then okay put this put
something through the middle of it and
then put stuff in the back and roll it
along and so these were crucial in and
we'll get to that in the next slide here
does anyone know what this is called
just shout it out they're still playing
yeah this world Silk Road Silk Route so
this is what about 2,000 years ago this
is about well this is probably the most
important trade route that was ever
established and
in the world and what you blue lines are
see lines so those are ocean lines and
then the red lines are land lines and I
was doing some research I was trying to
figure out how long it would take to
walk from Java to Europe take about six
months to walk and so because of the
wheel and because of a horse that can
average your speed or maybe about three
times the speed of like a human walking
you can different Java to Europe and
maybe around two months so makes it we
pretty grateful for planes right so this
was massive China was trading silk
horses were being traded and brought
around in different places it was a
massive advancement for civilization
also this was a really important way for
us to to progress politically and
culturally because people from Java were
able to meet people from Europe Asia was
able to meet Somalia Egypt China and
this was a great first starting point to
cultural development in geopolitics
alright this is money money's a really
massive advancement rather than just
bartering for things we now are able to
use things like coins and I really love
these coins I was just thinking about it
myself like Tigers and turtles dolphins
and like tools and I was just thinking
when we have like dead presidents on our
coins but they've done a lot but I think
these are really great ways to express
nature and those who this was massive
for being able to trade it was just
funny thinking about trying to go with
this is a this is a coin from from
Turkey and then this is from Greece and
so what I thought was really interesting
is like what if the Greek coin went to
Turkey and wasn't so I take I paid with
my points in they're like no we don't
accept your coins here so it's just
really nice that we now are able to use
currency across the world
friendly way all right another major
Advent to the human civilization so
we've jumped a quite a bit we've done
may be like a thousand years now from
about 500 so 1500 years ago to about 500
years ago this is the advent of the
printing press so this is an really good
work German made the way it works is
that you take this massive sheet put it
in here close the top there's holes in
the top then that goes and lays flat on
all these assemble assembled letters
that have ink on them you put them under
the printing press close it you push on
this really hard on this lever it pushes
down on and you pull it up and voila you
have a printed sheet and you can do that
so much faster look at how fast you can
do that and print Bibles the religions
spread like crazy because of this it's
not about five years ago and then we
move on to the admin of the telescope
I'm one of the one of the reasons why I
have a really quick quick story about
this is that it's crazy thinking about
how religion was so focused on the earth
being the center of the universe
that when Galileo and Bruno and
Copernicus said that is absolutely not
that then they Bruno got burned at the
stake
Bruno got burned at the stake Galileo
was incarcerated for his last ten years
under house arrest and they were just
trying to explain that the earth is not
the center of the universe and of the
Sun is the center of our solar system
and this is a microscope one of the
first microscopes so Thomas Edison
invented of trisomy he had a partner
that we worked with as well and Tesla
was obviously a major contributor to
this as well to electricity we go on to
the Ford Model T an incredible invention
for a transportation actually Henry Ford
sold 15 million Model T's
in 20 years great and you guys all know
his quote that if you would've asked
people what they want they were said
faster horses so penicillin a major
advancement and antibiotics being able
to play bacterial infection is crucial
this was around that was Henry Ford's
around 1910 this is around 18-49
now does anyone know if this is a map of
Facebook connection that's why
anything's close this is a map of
commercial flights so you can now take a
commercial flight and look at how many
lines there are if you created us fifty
five thousand commercial flight patterns
in that was in 2010 so it's probably
more now and it's just craziness you
know a 50 years ago was just the start
of like being able to travel anywhere
just like that remember it used to take
six months by walking or two months by
horse and now it's a 10-hour flight it's
incredible and this is earth rises of
Apollo 8 mission so we we went and this
was the first time that we had seen the
Earth from a view that was not on earth
and this was a really great perspective
shift for us I incorporated this picture
because I think it's really important to
talk about the ubiquity in food now we
have you know a chick-fil-a
like you know super easy to go get food
right next to is another food station
Taco Cabana so you can just go get food
whichever choice you want and then
furthermore you know there's about 1
million chickens killed per hour in the
US alone and I thought another
interesting point was all the cell
phones and iPad and stuff a lot of
people are now using technology to
either talk on social media or go across
the world or whatever could there be a
better experience for people here so
quick part 3 where are we going this is
this is this is clean meat as the
Memphis meats
this is biotechnology so this is being
able to grow beef from a stem cell of a
cow and Richard Branson and Billy
Melinda Gates Foundation Cargill all
these companies are now investing into
clean me rather than slaughtering those
animals this is a glass break this is
actually development of Madame gazelle
II over at UCSF super close by
the idea is to be able to map the neural
architecture of the brain and be able to
maybe understand how to prescribe a
videogame to somebody to help with their
ADHD rather than a pharmaceutical
also maybe understand the underlying on
principles of consciousness at some
point this is IBM Watson this is 2011
just kick the butts of humans at
jeopardy and then furthermore is now
being used for analyzing the new medical
research papers tons of other
advancements
this is an autonomous vehicle i'd like
to just briefly describe like like just
the environment dylan house is here it's
got all these cameras and sensors that
better understand its environment and
furthermore this is kind of how it
perceives its environment they'll see
like okay there's cars here those
pedestrians here at cetera this is one
of the biggest challenges of my opinion
too is to be able to read the traffic
light and understand the traffic rules
that it's in and then be able to make a
directional turn or give someone the
right-of-way at center that's all really
difficult to compute and understand this
is a Bitcoin mining farm in China
it's crazy china now has over 50% of all
the total Bitcoin mining systems there
and it's a cryptocurrency that is that
is currently exploding all over the web
as you guys know blockchain is a digital
ledger
[Music]
electracy no one can go back and change
it it's really interesting thing is
distributed across computers rather than
centralized
this is a really good way to understand
it it's a centralized power in one
location
this is distributed power this is like
how Google or how Facebook or how the
government works and this is how if
everyone had a computer and I was
talking one another with good behavior
in cyclization of their work this is
some space advanced mrs. James Webb
Space Telescope this is gonna be
launched in spring of 2019
this has a 21-foot mirror on the current
Hubble Space Telescope only has an
8-foot mirror on it
this is gonna enable us to look much
deeper into space and understand our
planets and stars reform it's also going
to enable us to analyze the composition
of atmospheres of exoplanets for life
this is Elon Musk sort of architecture
for Mars so this is us landing on Mars
hopefully in about 10-15 years and this
society will probably develop it closer
to 50 or whatever but it's it's an
incredible idea to expand the light of
consciousness to another orbiting rock
around the star that way you can't just
get extinguished by an asteroid like we
saw happen with the dinosaurs
furthermore just a little bit futurism
this is a nice experience an array of
satellites around a star and what's
really cool about that is if you harvest
the power of the star you can power your
civilization through it this is the
Kardashev scale so that's a civilization
that's only harnessing the power of its
own earth is about a 1 on the scale if
you harness the power of your stars
you're to on the scale if you harness
the power of all the stars in your
galaxy or about 3 on the scale and the
earth is kind of around 0.7 right now we
don't really even know how to harness
all the power yeah I like to explain
this is just a way of understanding like
the earth is currently kind of have you
guys ever heard of the zoo hypothesis so
the zoo hypothesis is just that the
reason why we're not in touch with
anyone right now is because there are
intelligent species that are currently
like
be in their natural habitat we don't
want to give them into any sort of we
don't want to infect them with with our
manipulations we want to see how they
evolve and stuff also is the reason why
there's cage around too is because earth
needs to do something to unlock a
connection to them and what they need to
do is potentially do something like
teleport will find world peace or get to
the next star and if you do that then
you last month they were lobotomizing
pumpkins now they're shoving bread up a
Turkey's ass this planet has issues
birth so I just gives you general idea
that are we in a computer simulation are
we not do you know I think therefore I
am but who knows
and I just like to end by talking about
how important it is to to really dive
deep into understanding the world around
us and teaching other kids to understand
the world around us from a young age and
understanding where we came from who we
are and where we're going that's it
thank you very much everyone well I
would say that probably 50% of what I
talked about is just a culmination of
what we hypothesize about over the past
which is really difficult
that's why submission that language is
one of the most under studied in under
under study